I very much share the description of
today's General Affairs Council it was
done by Madam President of the of the
Council for me it was such a comeback
after five years back to the general
offers family and it was very warm and
very long welcomed because indeed we've
been working from early morning until
just right now the rule of law I think
was very well explained by the
presidency then the very intense
discussion was about the preparation of
the European Council were I'm sure it's
not a surprise we very much discussed
the Green Deal which will be discussed
and I believe adopted tomorrow by the
Commission as a contribution to the
debate among our leaders were we in the
Commission what was clearly to underline
our ambition to remain the leader in
tackling climate change and where we
will present very comprehensive approach
how to really deal with this very urgent
and important issues from all aspects as
you know tomorrow we will be also
tabling Strode map how to achieve the
Green Deal we should also contain our
commitment to present the first ever
climate law which you would like to
table in the March of the next year the
discussion was very much about the
ambition versus costs were on the
commission behalf I was highlighting the
fact that we have to look at this as
very important investment which in the
end bring the revenue and I was also
highlighting the point which we will do
also tomorrow that what will be the cost
of non action which would be actually
horrible because you can count a lot of
things in money but you can you cannot
put a price on the human lives and if we
just look at the fact that if we
wouldn't act that we would lose 19
thousand people to the heat waves alone
this is just one exclamation point which
we would have
to highlight in the discussions when we
are talking about tackling the climate
change because simply if he wouldn't act
it - we would have to pay the highest
was in pricing the cost of human lives
in Europe and of course across the the
world I also underline all the financial
instruments and assistance which we are
ready to propose because I understand
and the member states have different
starting lines and we have to make sure
that no region no country no one is left
behind and therefore will be working
very hard on the just transition fund to
make sure that we would offer the fair
treatment to all member states and
regions to cope with the challenges of
more ambitious policy linked with the
Green Deal on mff again this was a very
long and detailed discussion I also like
to thank finish presidency for tabling
of a proposals I think that also after
today's debate it was quite clear that
we would need to work on this very
intensely hopefully the debates among
the leaders on Thursday will will push
us forward because what I think we need
in this case is not only the the good
deal with which all Member States could
live and support it but we need it on
time because with every months we are
losing time and we are now already at
the verge of being extremely tight to
start the next financial perspective on
time and if we will not do that it will
just lose a lot of opportunities with
using the the financial instrument for
the benefit of the European citizens so
what I suggested also was that we should
consider also to suggest to the new
President of the European Council will
now take over the negotiations to have a
special summit in February so we can try
to clinch the deal there and this would
be the message we would be able to pass
on and I know that the colleagues in the
room and especially incoming presidency
was listening very carefully to this
suggestion so we'll see how the debate
on Thursday among the lay leaders who
would
result in speeding up of the whole of
the whole process
I also informed the council about the
Commission's work program upon which we
are working very intensely we want to
table it in January it will very much be
focused on the six political priorities
of the president also upon the lion and
also on the strategic agenda tabled by
the European Council I was explaining I
would like to factor in the element of
strategic foresight and anticipatory
governance in the new programming and
and planning and of course we'll be
coming back to this issue with the new
presidency where we will plan the annual
program where we will be working
together with the Council on the
Parliament on declarations on the
priorities and I also informed the
council that we would like to come with
the first-ever multi-annual programming
in the middle of the next year and of
course the last item on the agenda
thanks to the Finnish presidency was
also information by my colleague
Commissioner for enlargement Oliver of
our Harry on his take on enlargement on
Western Balkans where we had also very
informative discussion and were we on
behalf of the Commission could reiterate
how important it is to have credible in
oxygen perspective for all countries in
the Western Balkans and that to be very
much stand by our proposal to open
accession talks with North Macedonia and
Albania and explain ahead of the Western
Balkans I mean in Zagreb and to conclude
I really would like it worse to thank
and then to congratulate the President
to Tootsie for excellent semester of the
Finnish presidency which was not easy
for for the European Union for the
Commission and I'm sure for the
presidency but they did it so
successfully that they not only managed
to have great presidency but also to
have a new government youngest prime
minister ever in the world
congratulations to her and
congratulations to Tootie because she
would continue to be our colleague as a
Europa First Minister
but on top of it you will be responsible
for the new big portfolio linked with
the state property so congratulations
and thank you very much for excellent
presents so we are ready to take
questions we start with Lily pyre here
in the front and please use micro and
apply yourself and your media